and like where where did you come from
who are you
who am I yeah I'm CIA your CIA
yes they put me on the algorithm
no I'm uh
well I started the internet thing on a
dating show called the Raj Patel where I
where this Jewish guy would pretend to
be an Indian and so it turned into the
Austin show but yeah they they found me
they scouted they're like Talent
scouting on the internet and they found
me and they put me on and then I pulled
it in on the girls on the E day
and then I got like a half a million
hits and that's how I started and then
well you pulled again another girl on a
date
all four of them
and they freaked out but it's like on a
webcam I can't even hear them you know
okay so it was an e day and you pulled a
gun on them and then they break down
yeah yeah and the clip went big and then
they almost kicked me off and then I
knew I had to win them over and stay on
the show and milk it and then uh every
time I was breaking like 3K 4K views
they would ban me and I needed money so
I would do like low quality stuff at a
thousand viewers just to get my sub
count up to like twenty thousand dollars
a month I was trying to make that was
like my goal and I hit that for a long
time
on YouTube or twitch
on on Twitch because uh yeah they said
as long as I'm like a low-level twitch
streamer they won't ban me like that's
kind of how it goes if you have too much
influence and you do a lot of mob gun
crazy [__] they'll they'll can your ass
so I said I'll just stay in my corner
with my community at a thousand viewers
and make money and I made my money and
then they Banned Me Again permanently
and I'm like the most banned streamer on
the website like they're streamers
who've had bomb threats
to get a Perma band but all I did was
like make jokes and I got perm abandoned
in my first week what did you so yeah
don't don't say the joke okay don't
don't say the joke oh what did you get
banned for like what what type of joke
was it
we don't know but I was pretty much
saying the stuff I say to women on fresh
and Fit I was saying it on those
left-leaning shows oh I see
havoc on Twitch
yeah yeah and then I got a lot of DMS
really weird DMS from the girls who were
trying to [__] me they would screenshot
the twitch admins that would flirt with
them and how they like conspire to keep
me banned if you if you stay around
Circa we're gonna ban him and stuff and
I had no idea that it's like that
personal and so uh I laid low you know
and even my brother and friends are like
dude you don't have you can't go back to
a regular life after these kind of Clips
you're not going to go back to security
stay at a thousand viewers do
reactionary just react content and
because you know I'm my commute is very
generous and so I would just do that and
heaps of money from especially for what
I'm used to
and then you know I was always
frustrated because I'm like man I can
never actually do this bigger streams
like I'd be afraid anytime the viewer
account will go up to 2K I start having
anxiety I'll be like oh [__] here comes
another four month break from this [__]
what type of content were you reacting
to is it red pill or was it more like
conservative content
you mostly it was red pill and dating
because uh when I did IRL picking up
women
I was picking them picking them up in
like eight seconds for big fat donations
and they're like can you break down what
you're doing because uh it looks like
hard for his like it looks like I'm just
winging it but it's instinct to me
because I worked at clubs for five years
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday for eight hours a night
so all I did is like
not even the night side because I was
like anti-social even the nights I
didn't talk to girls and stuff I would
study the guys who did talk to them and
I'd pick up on their habits and I you
know I would study that's all I ever
wanted when I was young is like women
because I lost my Virginia 20. so I was
like an adult who couldn't talk to women
I was like oh [__] I gotta learn this
and my buddies would make fun of me and
I'm very competitive so you know I was
like oh [__] you're at a 30 body count
you're at a 20 I'm at zero and they're
all laughing at me and then I played
ketchup in one summer and then had like
a head count of like a thousand girls
gave me head and that was because
in one in one summer
no it was like almost a year and a half
for that so in a year and a half but uh
you hooked up with a thousand chicks
easily yeah but it was uh only had never
ever risked pregnancy or any of that
because I had big phobias of that
and uh and first but I it wasn't like I
was into women like that it was more
like getting a lot of girls in my city
got me invited to the bigger parties and
the bigger paychecks right they'd be
like here's two thousand dollars come
with these rappers bring the girls we'll
give you two thousand dollars on the low
and so I could finally start making some
extra money because I was a bad in the
beginning
and uh so I'll use the women like as
currency really okay so so you were 20
years old and this was in Canada right
okay so so you were in Canada
um and you're a virgin at 20.
and then you realized you were bad with
women and so then in a year and a half
in order to sell drugs
you slept with a thousand women it
sounds crazy but that's exactly how it
went so you can go to it
basically when you're when you're when I
had women all around me following me in
town the Hell's Angels or the Immigrant
gangs they would bring me hey come to
the penthouse
and these guys were like we were very
rich and then they knew I'm not coming
for free so they treat it as like a host
they'd say I'm security but really I
would bring the party
and uh yeah it was like just Charming
the girls and then bringing them there
and uh yeah a lot of extra money like
that and but really I just want to get
connected so I could move more you know
yeah
so we're doing security at the same time
or no
yeah so straight from my shift at work
uh I spent four and a half or five you
know five years almost
I didn't see daylight for five years
that's imagine a depressed man not
seeing day left for five years or
friends or family because I'd always be
sleeping the day because of like all the
night jobs and uh
I loved it you know because I was like
daytime people look like civilians who
want to put me in jail for the things I
say nighttime people like understood me
but they're all demonic they're like
most of them are in jail now
all the night time like all the people
used to hang out with orange all my
friends I grew up with are either in
jail or waiting for their day they have
to go wow
wow and did you ever get in trouble for
it like did you ever get caught selling
well I got in a lot of trouble with the
law but never for that because uh when I
was driving around in the movie stuff I
would be clean-shaping in a suit and tie
and look like a white guy because I was
so obsessed with politics Optics the
stuff that I do on my stream I I would
just notice that hey at a checkpoint or
if there's doing a traffic stop the
white guy in a suit and tie would get
away with murder
so I wasn't like in a hoodie and looking
like gangster and [__] and then when I
got tattooed on the hand and I'd stick
my hand out on the [__] you know
driving I'd stick it out I had no idea
how much [__] trouble you get in for
hand ink like you just start getting
pulled over for no reason and yeah that
really like red pilled me on Optics is
everything and another thing was I'd
have an earpiece uh at work and I
wouldn't take it off so I can go into
any event because I would walk up to the
door and be like where's Selena we gotta
go now and then the whole [__] he works
here he's an authority and I'd walk into
big rapper shows for like no one would
stop me because I'd be so aggressive
like they think I'm an authority because
I have a [__] earpiece and I don't
even work at these events I was just
trying to get connected with people and
so then I realized like oh that's a
strong marketing strategy that if I get
on the internet and I'm the authority
people just collab with me and they go
oh [__] and so it even my first day on
the internet I was like I'm the [__] and
then they're like oh we believe you but
I was nothing as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible